[Music]
foreign
as a medical student and Resident I had
a wonderful infectious disease Mentor
who introduced me to colleagues of his
at the Peace Corps headquarters in
Washington DC where I was kind of
introduced to the world of infectious
disease epidemiology by people who were
incredibly committed to making a
difference in the world and then when I
came to Yale for my infectious disease
training I was welcomed into a research
lab that was focused again on parasitic
worms and neglected tropical diseases
and I think at each of those points my
mentors really helped me
crystallize in my mind why it was
important to work on diseases that are
endemic in some of the poorest parts of
the world and and also how research can
actually make a difference and help to
improve the lives of people who are at
risk of acquiring those infections
[Music]
foreign
most impressive about the scope of
research that's happening in EMD is that
it focuses on important infections that
are occurring literally around the
corner to what's happening on the other
side of the world and all of these
people are working together and in close
proximity and they're sharing their
their wisdom and their expertise and all
the while the mentoring students and one
of the things that our department that
EMD certainly is known for is not just
the ability to do Cutting Edge research
but also Hands-On intensely mentored
research experience to sort of fill in
that next generation of research leaders
foreign
[Music]
have made important contributions in
understanding the transmission of the
virus in developing new ways of
diagnosing infection in ways of tracking
transmission through genomics to
modeling the impact of vaccination and
other controlled measures through EMD
faculty we've led the contact tracing
program both locally as well as for the
state we co-chaired the governor's
commission that essentially helped to
advise on the state of Connecticut's
response and so I really can say with
confidence that there's not a single
unit on campus that has had a more
positive impact in helping to guide the
response in an evidence-based and
responsible way than EMD and frankly has
saved lives one of the things that was
made very clear from the pandemic was
the need for a larger more capable
Public Health Workforce that can predict
respond to and ultimately prevent the
next infectious disease epidemic it's a
perfect time for people interested in
public health to consider pursuing
training in infectious disease
epidemiology
[Music]